in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxarion, for June 20th, on which we commemorate, our Holy Father,
Nicholas Cabasilas.
Born in Thessalonica in about 1322, Saint Nicholas Cabasilas came from the Camitos family
on his father's side, but he later adopted his mother's family name of Cabasilas.
Out of an ancient and respected family, from his youth, he received his spiritual formation
from Dorotheus Blatis, a close disciple of St. Gregory Palamas, and frequented the circles
of devout layfolk who gave themselves to the practice of the Jesus Prayer.
Under the direction of St. Isador, Bukeras, the future patriarch, 1347-1350.
After having received his first literary and philosophical education from his uncle
Nilus Cabasilas, he went to continue his studies at the School of Philosophy in Constantinople.
He acquired there an advanced literary culture, and his admiration for classical antiquity
made him join humanist circles, without, however, digressing from the teaching of the church.
During his stay in the capital, the controversy between St. Gregory Palamas and Barlam, on the
possibility of the deification of man through the uncreated energies of grace, awakened his
attention to the ultimate goal of the Christian life, but he turned his attention rather towards
the social and political problems of his time.
After the death of Andronicus III in 1341, the empire found itself torn apart by a cruel
and disastrous civil war between the partisans of John V. Peliologus and those of John Catacusenus,
a situation that made the revolt of the zealots in Thessalonica against the imperial power
and the nobility even more serious.
Nicholas, finding himself in Thessalonica, took the initiative of negotiating between the
insurrectionists and John Catacusenus.
In 1345, he was sent to Borea as an ambassador to manual, the son of the representative of
Catacusenus, and he obtained the promise of advantageous conditions of surrender for the insurrectionists.
On his return, however, Andrew Peliologus opposed the project and stirring up the zealots
and the population of the squalid sections of the city, he launched an attack on the Citadel
in which the nobles had taken refuge.
Ignominius Slotter took place and Nicholas himself was only able to escape by hiding himself
in a well.
He remained in Thessalonica, however, until 1347, without being troubled, despite his known
sympathies for Catacusenus, and mediating on the causes of the civil war, he wrote several
treaties against usury and social injustice.
When Catacusenus took the throne with the title of John VI, he summoned Nicholas to him in
Constantinople and made him his counsellor in all the important affairs of state.
It was under the influence of Nicholas and his childhood friend, Demetrius Keithonus, whom
he characterized as men having arrived at the pinnacle of secular wisdom, no less philosophers
in their actions, and having chosen a chaste life exempt from the inconveniences of marriage,
with the emperor conceived the idea of retiring to the monastery of the Manga Nez.
But he had to renounce the idea because of the political situation in Thessalonica.
During the whole of this period, Nicholas gave himself to an intense literary activity,
while actively participating in public life.
In September 1347, he was part of the retinue that accompanied St. Gregory Palamas on his
election as Archbishop of Thessalonica.
But when the people rejected their shepherd, they both retired to Mount Athos, where they
lived in Isikia and prayed for a year.
In 1349, Nicholas returned to Thessalonica, where the zealots revolt having been quashed
and the opposing parties reconciled, the enthronement of St. Gregory could take place.
In 1351, during a council which condemned Akindinos and proclaimed Hessikasm as the official
doctrine of the church, Kabassilus openly took the side of Palomite theology and declared
himself favorable to the project of a council of union with a Latin church.
But without doctrinal compromise, while his friend, Gidonis, ranged himself on the side
of the enemies of Hessikasm and adopted an attitude of submission towards the Latin Theses.
While a new civil war broke out in 1353 between John V. Paleologus and John Catacusa Nus, which
led to the deposition of the patriarch St. Calistus I, Kabassilus' name was put forward
as a possible successor, but St. Philotheos was finally elected.
The following year, Nicholas greeted the coronation of Matthew Catacusa Nus as co-emperor with
a brilliant discourse.
But shortly afterwards, John Paleologus seized power with the help of Genoese mercenaries
and John Catacusa Nus was forced to abdicate and embraced the monastic life under the name
Joasav.
Patriarch Philotheos was deposed in his turn and sent into exile, and St. Calistus was summoned
back to be patriarch again.
At this point, Nicholas retired from public life and gave himself holy to meditation on
the mystery of Christ.
It is not known whether he remained a lay Hesse cast until his death or became a monk
as certain passages in his works seemed to suggest.
Apart from two years spent in Thessalonica, he spent the rest of this long period of retirement
in Constantinople, frequenting the monasteries of the Manganese, the Xanthopoulos, and the
Estudion.
He acquired the reputation of a man who had attained to the heights of virtue and important
figures in the empire, including Emperor Manuel Paleologus, sought his councils regarding him
as their spiritual father.
The saint, however, did not involve himself again in the troubles of the world, but preferred
to remain in silence, where he composed two major treatisees, a commentary on the holy
liturgy and the life in Christ which testified to his holiness, and are justly considered
as two masterpieces of Christian literature.
Nicholas fell asleep in peace between 1391 and 1397, without leaving any testimony to his
last days.
In the life in Christ, he shows how the faithful, receiving being, movement, and the true
life through the holy mysteries of baptism, chrismation, and the Eucharist, and growing spiritually
through the Holy Virtues, welcomed Christ himself through the powers of the Holy Spirit into
themselves.
He comes to dwell in them, and will grow in them until they reach the fulfillment of perfect
union with God.
The incarnation is the foundation of all spiritual life.
For having united what was separated, it has permitted communion, the mixture of created
and uncreated.
This life in Christ begins here below, but will find its fulfillment in the eternal kingdom
which is made accessible to us at present in the church.
Christ gives himself and mixes himself with each of his members through the sacraments as
light penetrates a room through the window, and he accomplishes the great mystery of his
nuptial union with humanity, introducing into our mortal changing body immortal and eternal
life.
This presence of the Lord, however, only becomes active if we collaborate synergy by responding
freely to God's gift, concentrating on doing nothing but guarding with vigilance the grace
received, like a flaming torch, waiting for the return of the bridegroom.
The spiritual life of Christians consists, therefore, in guarding their members and senses to
which Christ has united himself and in meditating on the honor which He has accorded us.
It is impossible to be drawn to evil once one has understood the love unto folly with which
Christ has loved us, going as far as to offer Himself in sacrifice on the cross, in order
to make of us His temple and His own members.
As such a person, the Lord becomes the only object of desire, and having acquired the Spirit
of Christ, the practice of the virtues becomes easy.
Growing in the Holy Virtues, and holy identifying His will with the will of the Lord, so that
His joy is found in that which gives joy to Christ, and His sadness in which He saddens
Him.
Divine love then becomes His common life, and the human person is able to participate in
the properties of the divine nature of the God-man.
This deification is the ultimate goal of a human being.
St. Nicholas saw it perfectly reflected in the person of the Mother of God, who by the beauty
of her soul, and by a will entirely surrendered to the designs of God, drew down the Holy Spirit,
so that the Savior might be born in her.
Following a different path to that of St. Gregory Palamas, St. Nicholas Cabasilas, a humanist
by formation, but a hessikast by vocation, knew how to show that deification and union
with Christ constitute the goal of the spiritual life of every Christian, and not only of monks
who retire far from the world and its preoccupations.
Transfiguring the positive elements of the humanist culture of His time and making Himself the master
of a sacramental hessikasm, He now occupies His rightful place in the choir of the Holy
Fathers of the Orthodox Church, since His recent insertion in the Church's calendar.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.